TIME PUCK DOWN UNDERWAY.
>> AMONG ALL
DEFENSEMEM NUMBER
TEN.
>> LOOK AT
BREAK, HE IS CAPPING IT OFF THE
BAR TO THE TAG TAG, HE GETS IT .
>> IT WOULD'VE BEEN A
>> REBOUND ONE
THEY A WHISTLE THERE LOOK
AT JAKE.
HE TRIES
BOUNCED OFF AND HITS TOOLLING PN
AND SETTLES IT BESIDE THE
POINTS TOTAL INMPORTANT.
PANTHERS, BACK AND FORTH UP
>> RODRIGUEZ WALKS IN, HE
RODRIGUEZ.
BUT HE GOES AWAY
HERE.
HE JUST GOES OFF THE STICK WHEN
HE RELEASES THE
EXCITEMENT ON THESE SCRAMBLES.
>> LOOKK PLAY POWER-PLAYES TO DE
WITH
>> COUGAR.
IT'S THE BLUE
LINE APPEARED A COUPLE OF
PLAYERS
>> THEY WILL HAVE TO JUMP ON IT.
QUICKLYERTIME. CLOCK.
.
>> SIX AND 11. THE SHOOT
>> PLAYING
EASY.S FLORIDA JONATHAN UBER.
HE PUTS IT IN.
>> ANOTHER PLAYER WITH SOFT
HA
>> HOW ABOUT THIS CARTER STARTSS